all the things you suggest with regards
to making social media an open public
thing are being done by Elon Musk right
now with regards to Twitter I that was
my favorite the buff
absolutely hilarious let yay back on let
yay back on Twitter censorship efforts
have failed and what better sign than
women just like just pearly things
I get a shout out yes
oh that's so funny oh my gosh what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today we are going
to be reacting to another mgtow video
called women are the language police now
I've been talking about this the reason
a lot of guys get irritated when women
go into men's spaces is because we go
into men's spaces and tell men how to
communicate it's kind of like the
audacity it's like men built this
Society they put it together for us they
say ladies all right you know what you
can come to work you can do it whatever
they're like please let me go to work
and we're like all right come on and
then we get to work and you know what
happens we start whining and this is the
theme I see with women whining I'm gonna
whine I'm gonna whine and I'm gonna wine
and [__] and wine and so we go into the
man's world and then whine about how the
men talk and I say if we're going to
live in a man's world I got no problem
but stop what whining whining whining
whining so why don't we pull up the
video this is from Sandman one of my
favorite video guys you know that I
react to all right women are the
language police let's go am I saying man
I sent this message regarding social
media's indirect influence I think that
it also uh I just said this last
reaction video I think where I know
where he's going nice to women's effect
on culture since they do so much talking
they both influence the culture and are
influenced by the culture they create it
may also shed some light on how Ultra
Rich Elites manipulate politics without
ever making a campaign donation the
power of any language cannot be
understated and to show the immense
power a prehistoric situation will best
show language's strength I take it back
to the Stone Age a caveman is hunting
and is a little hungry he sees a berry
bush with bright red quarter size fruit
on it before the caveman can grab some
here is rustling in the bushes a short
distance away sensing the potential for
an even greater feast in the form of a
deer or other animal he hides nearby
with his spearetti the animal emerges
showing itself as a deer the deer walks
over to the berry bush needs about 15
berries about 10 seconds after eating
those berries the deer jumps on its hind
legs and flops over Dead The Logical
thinking from our caveman is to see that
the berries are very poisonous and
should not be touched or eaten as the
caveman is inspecting the dead deer a
short distance from the bush his friend
comes over and is going to take some
berries from the bushnita the first
caveman says the prehistoric equivalent
of don't eat those berries you will die
and shows his friend the recently
deceased deer that they can instead cook
and eat while this story seems to show
language as an average power I would ask
for a do-over on the story but in this
version neither the caveman nor his
friend can communicate in any way verbal
or not most likely the only person to
have ever known the berries were
poisoned is would be the first caveman
and he doesn't or can't tell his friend
they would have to wait until another
deer comes along and ate the berries off
the bush to find out the massive power
of language shows itself in the fast and
efficient communication of important
information much the same if someone
discovered that berries are poisonous
some would eventually find out that we
could Farm food by planting seeds from
fruit trees or bushes in the ground thus
we have agriculture this powerful new
information would make its rounds and
people would start joining in on the
farming craze the cultural pillars of
farming include living off the land
staying in one place living in one place
and now you know why we call it
agriculture thanks to a stable food
supply population growth exploded and
the game of politics went from verbal
covert to physical overts now that the
origins of language culture and politics
have all been shown it is time to
understand how the rest respond to
social media social media and the
internet are a clever and far-reaching
form of language when online individuals
are often browsing with no clear purpose
and thus are moral into manipulation
both good and bad I do not think the
internet and social media should be
banned however it's simply an upgrade to
human language which means that it has
massive influence over culture and
politics social media should remain in
indifferent Town Square where people can
go without getting overtly or covertly
silenced if social media and its
influence on language is going to be
allowed then Shadow Banning algorithmic
disfavorability and deliberate
manipulation yeah I think it should
would be illegal to Shadow ban and I
think we should be able to sue companies
that silence us I think Banning should
all be illegal I think they should treat
social media like we treat phone it's a
communication technology and you cannot
silence anybody that's on it and because
conservatives will be like well it's
their own company they have free rights
whatever but it's like the left will
police us and everything I say we got to
pass some laws to police language or not
police that they cannot police language
of who gets bigger voices should not be
present it's a private company should
not apply to the Town Square which is
now online if these steps are taken the
far-reaching power of language and
social media should stay neutral and
fair an alternative option is to have
set algorithms be open source allowing
anyone to see the code behind it and
audit the algorithm pretty malicious
code well James thanks for the donation
as well as the topic all the things you
suggest with regards to making social
media an open public thing are being
done by you Elon Musk right now with
regards to Twitter he's also made it a
somewhat open source and uncensored
Public Square I know many of you might
not agree but at least that's the way
that I see it part of that is because he
fired all the sjws or let themselves
walk I that was my favorite the before
and after of the Twitter absolutely
hilarious he just got rid of all the
women and all the like beta men they
just were like gone he's like all right
all the people that actually know how to
code you can stay and that's why what
Elon Musk did is actually so crucial for
Humanity I feel like I get so much more
balanced news on Twitter like I almost
think Twitter is more accurate sometimes
than Google because Google will bring up
like the woke [__] first you kind of
have to sift through it but Twitter it's
like they don't they censor very little
the door it's the other platforms that
are infested let yay back on let yay
back on Twitter social justice Warriors
over the last 15 years because they were
making money hand over fist so they were
we're hiring equality officers and other
woke workers that's going to end if musk
monetizes Twitter with ads for video the
reason the censorship was there was
because there wasn't any real competitor
to the big social networks and women's
instinct is to police male language in
case Men start speaking the truth about
female nature
like when you're like yeah women are
terrible nowadays they're like not all
women like um I know a lot of people
that are not religious don't believe in
the Bible and they don't believe in the
story of Adam and Eve but there's a
reason why these stories exist think
about it eve eat the apple and only God
knows for how long she had knowledge I
was watching Adam running around naked
just think about the implication of that
only God knows how long he had that
knowledge that she could see obviously
that she was naked and then because the
Bible says yeah she ate the upper and
she gave it to Adam but it doesn't tell
us how long yeah to give Adam she
probably gave it to him when she got
bored and was like okay yeah I've seen
it all you know let me just relieve him
of his of his stupidity and it also
shows like the visceral reaction we get
from Red Pill content where they say
you're just hating on women you're just
Eve I'm just a massage and just a big
misogynist censorship efforts have
failed and what better sign than women
just like just pearly things red pilling
massive amounts of young guys these days
we've won and 63 of I get a shout
out nature but those censorship efforts
have failed and what better sign than
women just like just pearly things red
pilling massive amounts of young guys
these days we've won and 63 percent of
guys under 30 are single and that number
is only going to grow women have always
allowed men to speak about things like
which berries are poisonous and to warn
others about the beasts that lay outside
the cave opening in prehistoric times
but we men shaped a different language
so to speak one based on the material
world for the most part because we've
had an interest in things mostly for
basic survival instead of people our
language skills evolve differently
because of our separation with women
laboring at home and men laboring in the
fields or forests but today neither of
us have to do that so the so-called
codependency between the Sexes has come
to an end all social media was free
until about time that's interesting yeah
because in a way they've kind of
automated everything you know what I
mean like women obviously need men more
than men need women but because of like
the way society's structured it's like
you can get an apartment you still have
the safety from the the government you
can still get money from the government
so women aren't dependent on men and men
it's like you can get ubereats like you
don't need the comfort of a chick you
can get a hooker like you can buy
everything that you really would need
and now women have the sperm banks it's
interesting to me that men don't do
surrogacy you know it's interesting like
women will go get a child but like men
don't do the same thing as much
typically are the ones that push
morality yeah oh yeah
20 years ago when women started using it
and then the censorship started I was
emailing a YouTuber named wonderhouse
you all back about Rumble and I
suggested that you try it and she looked
at it and mentioned that everyone on
there was looking like they were
angering yelling at each other in the
thumbnails that's the thing places like
YouTube have to sanitize the content to
attract female audiences they make most
the spending decisions for the typical
household and thus uh so he's saying
Twitter is going to get ruined when they
make ads on videos because women are the
ones that spend now for women didn't
vote where would this money come from
because we wouldn't have all the
government handouts the credit card
company like before that women they were
like oh women couldn't get a bank
account or credit card there was a
reason there was a reason that we
couldn't we couldn't be trusted I think
women still could in like certain
circumstances but one women were married
like 85 percent of us were married we
weren't worried about a credit card our
husband had it responsible for the
advertising dollars that are spent there
Wonder Huskies pretty much opened the
new ideas and uses colorful language
it's not always 100 politically correct
with wonderful old western sayings and
she was still turned off by All Tech to
some extent so what do you think is
going to happen to the average woman
it'll probably offend enough of them to
take jobs in such places just so they
can go in there and censor content they
don't like I had this thought I'm not
going to say it but you know thinking
worked well while there was only one
YouTube but now there's at least half a
dozen video sharing platforms that are
here to say they can't control
everything anymore that's why for a
while you saw places like Twitter banned
bit shoot links which they still do for
some reason but they don't ban Rumble
women have always had the power to
influence the culture because of male
validation men generally behave in ways
women want to get their approval but
what happens when technology eventually
makes female validation irrelevant then
female influence will no longer be
important your point about language
James is interesting all languages is an
extension of the mind and cognition it's
a form of Technology Marshall mcluhan
the big Canadian thinker before Jordan
Peterson spoke about how all technology
is an extension of the body the spear is
an extension of the hand same with every
projectile weapon that we've created the
wheel is an extension of the feet same
as the domestication of the horse social
media is nothing more than an extension
of voice and language allowing it to
travel great distances that's really
interesting that's so true what's a
plane an extension of the feet what's a
plane an extension of what fee because I
guess feet travel remember that when
Julius Caesar was deleted in the Roman
Forum Mark Anthony delivered a speech
afterwards and only the people in The
Forum 10 000 or so could actually hear
him obviously there were no microphones
so all Technologies about amplifying
human ability Marshall mcluhan also said
that the medium is the message that each
medium changes the way that information
is being conveyed having a face-to-face
conversation is totally different than
posting something on I wonder if his
premise is right that basically the more
men see content like this and realize
that one the value of women is down
which I mean come on men kind of realize
this anyway but two that like when
there's more Alternatives like there's
AI Bots or whatever I wonder if men like
chasing female validation I honestly
don't see it getting better
unfortunately maybe this type of content
will help but I'm just thinking out loud
will the the price or like the the
benefit of female validation go down in
the next couple of years and will more
men why eyes up or will more men I guess
men are logical I think when they see
their grandpa and their fathers get
screwed over by the same system and the
same women they might I'm undecided on
this social media people like myself
have learned to amass a sizable
following online that we never would
have achieved in real life the opposite
is often true for many people that are
popular in real life but have become
attention bankrupt online because it's a
totally different means of communication
it's no wonder that women have
controlled language and the conveyance
of information for most of our species
their emotional angst and constant need
for an emotional tampon I've just had
these thoughts and
it's funny because if we were to look at
social media and obviously I'm Catholic
I'm Christian so I believe in the word
of God and stuff but by social media
alone a lot of women are not going to
make Heaven just think about it look at
how many women are deliberately shaking
their ass on social media oh yeah to
spread degeneracy like obviously I'm not
I'm not trying to be like this guy
trying to stand on a moral High Ground
just pointing out reality in it right I
I know I have my own sins that are
coming but like I'm just saying if we're
to just look at social media literally a
lot of women are not going to make
Heaven they are literally doing the work
of the devil I actually I wonder if
there's some immorality and not having
children like sometimes I wonder if
that's a sin if if you can and you don't
yeah I think so yeah because some people
will say like some women are called the
singleness and the church I'm like I
don't think women are the only people
that are called to singleness are men
because it's literally in the curse that
was placed on man you will tell the
Earth like like if you look at because
God gave adam and if there are two
completely different things part of
man's curse is that he would work and he
might not see the fruit of his label and
that's kind of what they're doing
because they basically steal men's man
it's like weird when you start to think
about it I I genuinely think that men
have their money stolen from them from
women because it's like all like for I
just keep thinking 45 of men run Society
how does a bus driver only make 35 40
000 pounds a year when we need bus
drivers it's like we take the money from
the men and give it to the women and
it's like how do these women in HR make
more money than them like that doesn't
make any sense like I I had a roommate
that worked in HR she made like 60k a
year which in in I mean British pounds I
don't know what that is but at the time
because the currency is inflated a lot
but at the time she was like one of the
highest paid like people I knew
um like she was right out of college
making 60 Grand a year in HR you know
what I mean so it's like the guys at the
top will take money from the men
actually doing [__] and just give it to
the women they don't want the men to
have resources yeah because then because
when men have resources and men can
stand up against the government
yeah well and I think there's a lot of
guys that are just like blue pill you
know what I mean so it's like I just
think there's a natural bias towards I
think like men will always have a
natural bias to protect women and to
give us what we want like I just think
that's like in them and I think that's
why women have never had the right to
vote because that's too much power
because you have the power of already
being able to influence men and and you
have the power of like then you also
have your own political power which
really isn't influenced by men because
men do not have sympathy or women which
is not like the the power that women
like women's voting power is not
influenced by men except for propaganda
but women will vote in our own best
interest because we don't have sympathy
for men and especially not average men
like we don't feel sympathy the same way
may have just as likely been responsible
for the rise in language they couldn't
Express your frustrations with men
physically because we'd put them in
their place physically but doing a
verbal assault on our senses with
language would be an assault on us that
we couldn't repel and a field of battle
where we could hardly win so you can
understand why when social media and
YouTube started spreading information
about female nature in the 2010s why
they freaked out because they lost their
cooch control of the information that
shaped man's Minds it was an existential
crisis that freaked them out I don't
think it's meant they were responsible
for the development of language but it's
more likely that women were as a
mechanism to gain better control over us
and deal with their emotions there's a
very real possibility now that AI is
going to become so good at manipulating
both men and women with language that
whoever controls it will be able to
control huge chunks of the human
population technology that knows you
better than you know yourself will
probably be able to get you to do things
to go against your best interests
without you even realizing it in a world
like that the individuals that have the
least amount of trust in other human
beings and most likely technology as
well will probably win because if you
already refuse to trust most humans and
their intentions you're a lot less
likely to trust AI as well even the
Godfather of AI is super worried about
that it'll become the real language
please because it'll be the biggest
influence in the world influencing
Society on the level of the individual
as well as the collective but it won't
be conscious at first it'll just be
hyper intelligent and right now it's the
wokesers and women that are controlling
the development of AI and if you watch
the open AI video from the creators of
Chachi PT then you'll know what I'm
talking about anyways that's it for
today I have been saying this I've been
saying it because I literally did not
understand the visceral reaction and me
coming in the men's space I was like
guys I'm here to have a good time I'm
here to learn like like teach Pearl I'm
here to study this stuff whatever and I
was like gosh a lot of these guys are
not friendly I'm like wow they are not a
taken accustomed and they're they're
just saying I'm like gonna do all these
things but then I joined the space and I
was like oh wow I would do the same
thing if I was a dude it's like we try
we finally made this space and now all
the women come in to police our language
I'd be irritated as hell like they keep
they keep trying to make these spaces
that were and then we just keep getting
I mean I like to think YouTube is free
right talk about anything but I really
understand where the dudes are coming
from in all honesty um but you know let
me know what you guys think in the
comments
um do women police men's language
comment below like the video I'd like to
get to over a thousand likes subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time